All right.
So hopefully you have a better
understanding of why
OnClickListener is an interface
with an abstract method called OnClick.
Your role as the developer is to
set up the event listeners for
the input events you want
to handle in your app.
More specifically, for each listener
you will need to follow three steps.
Number 1, define the event listener and
the custom behavior or
when the event happens.
Number 2, create a new object instance
of the event listener by
calling the constructor.
And number 3, attach the listener to the
view you want to listen for events on.
And then I'll show you the code
you need at each step.
First we need to define an event
listener class that implements
the interface.
You can call it anything you want as
long as it follows the Java conventions
for naming classes.
In this case,
we named the class NumbersClickListener.
And this code is located in a new filed
called, NumbersClickListener.java.
When we define the NumbersClickListener
class, the declaration should say,
public class, followed by the name
of the class, followed by the word
implements, and then the interface name,
which is OnClickListener in this case.
So note that implements is a Java
key word that has a special meaning.
And you can find a list of
these special key words
in the Java Oracle documentation here.
We use implements to express that the
NumbersClickListener class will support
the specified interface and provide
code for all it's abstract methods.
By implementing
the OnClickListener interface, for
every piece in the Android code that
expects an OnClickListener object type,
we can use the NumbersClickListener.
And right before the method we
have this @Override annotation.
This means that we are overriding
the blank method in the interface and
providing our own implementation.
Our implementation of the OnClick method
is that we want a toast message to pop
up that says, open the list of numbers.
We could've provided any
other customer behavior here.
This is just an example.
Once we define our numbers,
clickListener class.
We need to create
an object instance of it.
If you remember from the last course,
we have the class template, but
we need to create
object instances of it.
We just created a floor plan,
but we need an actual house.
Remember back to the syntax for
creating an object using a constructor.
To create a NumbersClickListener
object instance,
we can call the constructor for
the class with the new keyword.
This creates a new object that
we can store in this variable
on the left-hand side,
where the variable is of this data type.
Within the Miwok app,
this is what the code looks
like in the main activity file.
We modify the main activity so that we
can immediately start listening for
click events as soon as
the activity is created.
We're creating a new
NumbersClickListener object and
storing it in a variable
called ClickListener,
which is of the variable data
type NumbersClickListener.
So once we have an object instance
of a NumbersClickListener,
we need to attach it to the view that
we want to listen for clicks on.
And this is the code for that.
Assuming we have the view stored
as a variable, called buttonView,
we just need to call the set
OnClickListener method on that view and
pass in one parameter argument,
the ClickListener variable.
Well how do we know to call this method
with this particular input argument?
Back to our handy dandy documentation.
Here we'll take a look at the View
class, and it has a method
called setOnClickListener,
where you pass in an OnClickListener.
Since the NumbersClickListener
implements this interface
It is also considered
an OnClickListener data type, and
we can pass that in as
an input to the method.
Now let's see what the code looks
like within the context of the app.
However, you won't need to
make these changes just yet.
The quiz in the next video will
give you more specific instructions
on what we need to do.
So just follow along and
try to understand the logic.
So here I've created
a NumbersClickListener class, and
defined it in it's own Java file.
Remember that we specify
the package name in the code so
that our code is bundled under
this unique package name.
Then we have the import statements,
because we're using the View and
Toast classes.
And we can use them even though
we didn't create them ourselves,
because we're importing them.
Then in the class declaration,
we have implements View.OnClickListener.
And I'd like to point out that
we add View.OnClickListener
to be very explicit that we're
referring to the OnClickListener
that is part of the view.java
file in this package.
And recall that we use the .operator
to access Java class members.
So here in the NumbersClickListener,
I have created an onClick method.
And in it I've said when
the numbers category is clicked on,
we choose to display a Toast message
that says, open the list of numbers.
And there you have it.
This is the NumbersClickListener.
Now I'm going to switch
over to main activity.
And at the end of the OnCreate method,
we need to create a new
ClickListener object.
Now we need to attach the ClickListener
to the numbers category view.
However, first we need to find that
view object in the viewer hierarchy.
And this process should be familiar from
the Just Java app in the last course.
So here's how we're
going to write that code.
So to find the view that
shows the number category.
So here I call
the findViewById method and
request the view with the ID numbers.
So once we find the text view,
we can store in a variable that
I'm going to call numbers.
Then we can call the set OnClickListener
method on this text view and
pass the ClickListener object as input.
So here's how that would look.
So here we set the OnClickListener
method on the text view in passing
the ClickListener object as it's input.
So the TextView numbers in our case
will store the clickListener object.
And later, if this TextView is pressed,
the ClickListener jumps into action.
In order to test that this Java
code I wrote actually works,
I have to delete some old code that
we wrote from the button click.
So in the activity_main XML file,
I'll need to delete the Android onClick
attribute on the numbers TextView.
So in the main activity I'll also need
to remove the open numbers list method.
And this leaves the main activity
with one method, the onCreate method.
Now when I run the app on my device,
clicking the numbers category
pops up a toast message.
Great.
Now my ClickListener code is working.